O!Sapiens Expert: Hey, Martin.
Martin: Hello young man, how is that?
O!Sapiens Expert: How are you?
O!Sapiens Expert: Good. Yeah, how are you?
Martin: Yeah, good, fine, cool.
O!Sapiens Expert: You look, you look leaner.
Martin: Yes, I look…
Martin: Yes. From day to day I lose weight. Yes.
O!Sapiens Expert: Nice. How's the water festing?
Martin: Yeah.
Martin: Water fasting is brilliant.
Martin: It's really brilliant. I mean, it's an easy protocol.
Martin: I mean, if you're healthy, you cannot do a lot of mistakes, I think.
O!Sapiens Expert: Aha.
Martin: And if you don't forget to drink the water, yes, then it's now it's really cool.
O!Sapiens Expert: Wow, that's really good. That's really promising. How was the overall?
Martin: Ja.
Martin: Hä.
O!Sapiens Expert: How is overall the state of health and everything?
Martin: Yeah ist gut, gut.
O!Sapiens Expert: Very nice.
Martin: Die.
O!Sapiens Expert: So you're back home, huh?
Martin: Ist.
O!Sapiens Expert: All right. Congrats. That's a massive change.
Martin: Ja Harvard, You.
O!Sapiens Expert: Took some time, huh?
O!Sapiens Expert: Well, you know, trying to stick to healthy habits, routines and all this, but eventually have some issues with health, but you know, my autoimmune condition is like emerging and disappearing, emerging and disappearing, but overall kind of stable.
Martin: Okay, Cool.
O!Sapiens Expert: Yeah, thank you.
Martin: Cool.
O!Sapiens Expert: I want to check with Wesley, he's supposed to connect as well, but I don't know if he's connecting. Okay, let's start a meeting anyways, and we'll see how it goes. If he connects, good. If not, I'll just share a transcript with him.
O!Sapiens Expert: So tell me, how was that retreat center in Portugal? What do you…
Martin: In.
Martin: In one and a half week, I'm there.
O!Sapiens Expert: Okay.
Martin: Ist.
Martin: So until now, they do a lot of gatherings and meetings, online meetings and collaboration, but that didn't really start it yet. There were other issues.
Martin: other projects. So yeah, I will be there and then I know more. Yeah.
O!Sapiens Expert: Mmhm.
O!Sapiens Expert: Okay, that's… it was good, but are you planning to be there often, or is it just, like, one-off, or what's it.
Martin: Yeah, thank you.
O!Sapiens Expert: Like, what's your commitment with them?
Martin: I'm a member now, so I paid 10,000 to be a member and to collaborate in the development. And I have a slot to buy an unit.
O!Sapiens Expert: Hi.
O!Sapiens Expert: Oh, nice.
Martin: And in the next two, three months. And if I don't want to have this lot, then I can also sell it again to someone else. Yeah.
O!Sapiens Expert: Oh, cool!
O!Sapiens Expert: I see. Lot, as in, like, plot of land? Or, like, a unit that's already built?
Martin: No, it's nothing built. Nothing built yet. It's gonna start now, and then they're gonna… construction phase one will be, uh…
Martin: Start of next year. Yeah.
O!Sapiens Expert: I see. Okay. That's interesting.
Martin: Many of these projects you buy, yeah, in the stage of the project, not finished yet, I think, yeah.
O!Sapiens Expert: Mm-hmm, I see.
Martin: How is the relation to this, to this Thai, uh, guy? It's not a Thai guy, but it's a Thai project?
O!Sapiens Expert: Yeah, it is a Thai project, he's American-French, basically, and the plot of land that he owns is located in Don Sac, and I don't know if you're familiar with that area, like, you know Samui.
Martin: Yeah, yeah.
Martin: I know where it is, yes, yes, yes. I have an idea.
O!Sapiens Expert: Right, so in Donsai, Donsai is not that developed in terms of tourism because people mainly go to Samui and Koppengan and other locations, but Donsai is becoming, you know, slightly more developed in terms of infrastructure, in terms of everything.
O!Sapiens Expert: So, he's got a plot of land in there, and I… well, we agreed to collaborate on this, and see if we could develop this into something bigger, a project. And then, currently… well, this is the concept that you've seen, basically, and now we're into.
O!Sapiens Expert: you know, trying to understand if there's traction, having conversations with people, because, again, it requires additional investments to build this, like, in your place. Like, if there's traction and interest, we can then build it and make it happen, and then scale it, potentially. But, of course.
Martin: Okay.
O!Sapiens Expert: Yeah, it requires time and attention.
O!Sapiens Expert: Overall, the general idea is to build it like a resort type of place, where you can go, where you can stay, where you can do various types of workshops, activities, you know, health-related things, like spa, for instance, but it's more of a boutique, it's not, like, major development, you know, it's more like…
Martin: Okay.
O!Sapiens Expert: I don't know how to compare it. Of course, it's not like the retreat that we've been to Costa Rica. I mean, that place is enormous. Their square footage is insane. This is more smaller, of course, but supposed to be more condensed.
Martin: Yeah, yeah.
Martin: Okay, okay.
O!Sapiens Expert: So how did you connect with these guys in Portugal?
Martin: I found it on TikTok and then had a call. Yeah, then I had a call. Then I saw all the videos. And it's a good process. It's really very cool, cool, cool, nice process they established. Yes.
O!Sapiens Expert: Really?
Martin: And, uh, so I had two calls. I had also a call with Dion, with the founder, and then… Yeah, now it's really… My structure is everything. Process, structure, and then, uh…
Martin: Yes, involvement of the people, that's new, you know, that you really have the chance to, yeah, to develop some areas when it comes to food, when it comes to health and wellness, there's several groups, you know.
Martin: Working on these issues. Yeah, cool.
O!Sapiens Expert: Wow, amazing. So, for the amount of money that you pay them, what do they offer?
Martin: For this 10,000, you mean?
O!Sapiens Expert: Uh-huh, yeah.
Martin: I mean, this is… this is… they want a kind of commitment, you know? They want… they want to really, uh, have a commitment of people who really, uh, are…
O!Sapiens Expert: Oh.
O!Sapiens Expert: Click interested.
Martin: willing to contribute this project now. So this is, and then the slot you have, yeah, you have a slot where you can buy. And then, of course, at the end of the day, the 10,000 is part of the price.
Martin: Of course.
O!Sapiens Expert: Mmhm.
Martin: And yeah, but it's good. It's a good idea. Otherwise you communicate with the whole world and have all this bullshit questions and.
O!Sapiens Expert: Let me see.
Martin: You know? So, yeah.
Martin: But that that is I like that. I like the idea. And yes, if I want to get out again after 2 months, then then.
O!Sapiens Expert: Umm.
Martin: I'm gonna sell this 10,000 again, you know, to someone, to them back, or to someone else. So, at the moment, I trust them.
O!Sapiens Expert: Mmhm.
Martin: And yeah, if it's a big, I don't think it's a failure, but you never know what happens.
O!Sapiens Expert: No, but they already have something built. It's not like they're building it from scratch, right?
Martin: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
O!Sapiens Expert: So it's been there for some time now. And what type of retreats are they hosting?
Martin: Yeah.
Martin: ah.
Martin: No retreat. They have some experience with other retreats and they have a guy who is really into building resorts and he has built already two, three resorts, but not the community.
O!Sapiens Expert: Mmhm.
Martin: But the traditional, yeah, it's good architect, it's a good developer, yeah.
O!Sapiens Expert: Hmmm.
Martin: But I didn't, I was not there. So community is new land for them. Yeah, they had two of them. They already build other projects, but not in the community building.
Martin: Yes.
O!Sapiens Expert: And are they working with medicine?
Martin: Yes. I asked him, how about this? Are you open? He said, yeah, look, until now we have 200 people who are signed up as members and about 20 have experience with.
O!Sapiens Expert: Very nice.
Martin: with substances and medicine and are interested to do something. Yeah, Portugal is good, you know, I think.
O!Sapiens Expert: Oh, nice.
O!Sapiens Expert: I know, I know.
Martin: Yeah, you know the situation.
O!Sapiens Expert: Everything's decriminalized. It's not legalized though, but nobody gives a shit, it seems.
Martin: Yeah.
Martin: Yeah, yeah.
O!Sapiens Expert: So you're… but now you're based in Switzerland back, right? Or you're heading again to Southeast Asia or wherever?
Martin: Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Martin: No, man, now I really like it to be here. It's, you know, it's very hot in Europe, but here in the Alps, it's…
Martin: It's chilly, so it's really cool. So, yeah, and then as soon as I want to leave, I think I will leave to Asia, but I don't know where, I don't know when. So, but for sure, if there's a project there and they already start to build, then yeah.
O!Sapiens Expert: Yeah, I know.
Martin: I will I will have a visit.
Martin: I will visit them for sure.
O!Sapiens Expert: I see. Okay. Yeah, no, it's good to be in the Alps now at Barcelona. It's 32, 33, every single day since June 1st.
Martin: Okay.
O!Sapiens Expert: It's crazy.
O!Sapiens Expert: It's like five degrees more hotter than an average in history observations. Global climate change is hitting hard.
Martin: Yeah, yeah.
Martin: Yeah.
O!Sapiens Expert: Well, you know, it's fun. At least there's a senior boy.
O!Sapiens Expert: Which is good. So have you got in touch with any of our cohort members, or are you just flying by yourself?
Martin: No, no, no, no. Yeah, yeah, yeah. You? You have contact?
O!Sapiens Expert: No, I met with Asim in December. I went to South Africa there and I went for an Ibogaine ceremony. And then I met with him. He was there. It was really nice to catch up. But no, I haven't seen anyone. They're like concentrated in US. It's just ridiculous. He opened that signal channel.
Martin: Yeah, I don't know.
O!Sapiens Expert: And everyone's talking about a client here, a client there, and it's just, like, US-based. It's just like, well, what am I doing here? It's kind of pointless, completely. But, yeah, anyway…
Martin: Okay.
O!Sapiens Expert: Bit of weird, trying to build my own network here in Barcelona, but it takes time, of course.
O!Sapiens Expert: You know, starting from scratch, a bit challenging, but hey, it's been a year now.
Martin: Okay.
O!Sapiens Expert: Full adjusting.
Martin: But you have a girlfriend, you said, huh?
O!Sapiens Expert: Yeah, yeah, yeah, I don't know.
Martin: A Spain, a Spain lady.
O!Sapiens Expert: Thanks.
O!Sapiens Expert: No, no, no, she's not. Brazilian-Israeli. Beautiful, beautiful soul, yeah.
Martin: Mmm!
Martin: Cool. Cool.
O!Sapiens Expert: And we're really beautiful and loving relationship.
Martin: Wow, cool.
O!Sapiens Expert: Yeah, it's nice.
O!Sapiens Expert: So, um, tell me about the things that you wanted to share about the project. Is there something that's worth… like, something that piqued your interest, or something that is just worth knowing? You know, first of all, I want to know about the project in Portugal, and then we'll switch to Thailand, yes.
Martin: About talent.
Martin: Uh-huh, uh-huh.
O!Sapiens Expert: Like, if there's something that, you know, could be useful, or something that, uh, blew your mind, or something that, you know, you felt like that's kind of strange…
Martin: Uh, okay.
Martin: You're talking about what now? About this…
O!Sapiens Expert: the Portuguese that you are involved in right now? Because you said that you could share something about them, and I'm just curious, like, if there's something interesting.
Martin: Uh-huh.
Martin: Aha!
Martin: Uh, not, not now.
Martin: I wanted to go a little bit more into the… this working groups and taking part, but I had no time, so… so I don't know actually more, so I decided, look, I'm a person, people, so I want to meet them all in…
Martin: in Portugal, end of August.
O!Sapiens Expert: Aha.
Martin: And then we're gonna have a.
Martin: Uh, we're gonna check the site there, and then we'll stay for another 4 or 5 days in Portugal, and then go back. I think then I will know, really.
Martin: Yeah, it's… it's… if it's mine… it's… it's… what I like, it's international.
O!Sapiens Expert: Mmhm.
Martin: But what I don't like is…
Martin: Already a little bit too American.
Martin: You know, if you're American, you know, to…
O!Sapiens Expert: In what way?
O!Sapiens Expert: But you mean like the owners are American or just the management style?
Martin: No, no, no, the members, you know.
O!Sapiens Expert: The members, okay.
Martin: If you have then… and they're very dominant, and they're very loud, and they're very…
O!Sapiens Expert: For Americans.
Martin: And this, this is, this is, okay, this is the only critical point at the moment when I see.
Martin: When it is a Zoom meeting, and then all these questions, and this bullshit, and this… Okay, so…
O!Sapiens Expert: Okay.
Martin: You know, this is the only little doubt I have in the moment.
O!Sapiens Expert: But you're talking about the people who also signed up like you, those are the Americans, okay.
Martin: Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Martin: A lot of expectations, a lot of…
O!Sapiens Expert: Mirror.
Martin: Always talking and telling and yeah.
Martin: Deb?
Martin: You you remember. You remember the the integration meetings also in in in in.
O!Sapiens Expert: Well, the typical American style.
O!Sapiens Expert: Oh.
Martin: Costa Rica.
O!Sapiens Expert: Yes.
Martin: Yeah, please, can you share what you experienced the last night? And then they talk about everything. They talk about everything, what comes to their mind.
Martin: Their parents and the children and…
O!Sapiens Expert: Yeah, life history.
Martin: Life history. Oh my God. Okay.
O!Sapiens Expert: That's funny.
Martin: Yeah, that's, uh, I mean…
O!Sapiens Expert: Thank you.
Martin: Yeah, I mean, no group should be dominant.
Martin: I mean, yeah.
O!Sapiens Expert: So much for inclusion in diversity.
Martin: That's that.
Martin: Yes, this is, yeah, this is important for me.
O!Sapiens Expert: Okay, okay. And just to quickly understand the concept that they're promising, so you made the first installment and then if you're interested, you're paying for it and then they will build like a house?
O!Sapiens Expert: That will be, like, assigned to you, but then you can, like, rent it from… or take it from time to time, and the rest of the time it's rented to someone else.
Martin: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Martin: Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah, this kind of thing. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
O!Sapiens Expert: Oh, I see. And do you have, like, a fixed amount of nights per year, or how does it work?
Martin: No, no, no, no, I don't think so. This is not worked out properly. This is… I think this is under construction. This kind… how do you sell? When do you sell?
O!Sapiens Expert: Oh.
Martin: Yeah, but for sure.
O!Sapiens Expert: Right.
O!Sapiens Expert: No, I understand that under construction, it's more of like the general idea. What is it? It's just like they build you a piece of property, that's it. You own it.
Martin: Yes, you own it. And then you have a lot of shared community, of course. You have this gym and this yoga center and this also farmer land and gardening. There's a lot of community.
O!Sapiens Expert: Okay.
O!Sapiens Expert: Huh?
O!Sapiens Expert: Uh-huh.
Martin: things. And there it's it's it's up to you how much you contribute and how much you you also can build your own business there. This is important. If you want to should to have a yoga class, if you want to, then.
Martin: It's up to you, not in the name of the organization. Then they have the platform, you can do that there.
O!Sapiens Expert: Where is she?
O!Sapiens Expert: I see Wesley. Hi. Can you hear us?
wesley: Hi. Yes?
O!Sapiens Expert: Wonderful. Wesley, meet Martin. Martin, meet Wesley.
Martin: Oh.
Martin: Hello, Wesley.
wesley: Hey, how are you?
Martin: Wonderful, how about you? Fine?
wesley: Nice to meet you.
wesley: Great, great, I'm good.
Martin: Wonderful.
Martin: Cool.
O!Sapiens Expert: We're just talking about the project in Portugal, but I think it would be nice if you guys get to know each other and introduce a bit, and then we could talk about the project in Thailand.
Martin: Yeah, cool. So…
wesley: Sure.
O!Sapiens Expert: 'Cause the…
Martin: Shall I start?
wesley: Yes?
Martin: So, yes, I'm, uh…
Martin: Martin, I know Vlad from Psychedelic Retreat Education. We did three years ago in the US. I'm 67. I live in Switzerland.
Martin: But I work as an independent trainer, coach for executives, leadership development, organizational development. This is my work.
Martin: I worked a lot in the corporate industry.
Martin: So, I had some health issues, so I decided half a year to spend in Asia, and while I was there, mainly in Bali.
Martin: Uh, in Thailand, I also, um, was looking for places where I could live longer time. So, uh, longevity is a topic, a little bit community, uh, health.
Martin: But, uh, all what I found is, uh, yeah, it's only a little bit, uh, corporate, blah, blah, marketing, talking, but not really community-based, uh.
Martin: infrastructure, so I was a little bit disappointed with all the projects I saw.
Martin: So then I came here to Europe again, and then also I'm looking around a little bit.
Martin: there's a project in Portugal where I could be interested, so my idea is to live somewhere, to have a Plan B destination.
Martin: I can live 2, 3, 4 months a year, and the rest of the time I can, yeah, rent it to other people.
Martin: Manage property somehow. And when I'm there, yes.
Martin: For myself, yoga…
Martin: Breathwork.
Martin: Healthy food.
Martin: and also possible to contribute a little bit to ORL.
Martin: to offer a few things where I'm talented in, and yeah, that's what I'm looking for. So then I was telling the story to.
Martin: To, uh, flat, and then…
Martin: He said, oh…
Martin: Something, I know a good project in Thailand.
Martin: There we are.
O!Sapiens Expert: Em.
wesley: Yes, it's pretty much what we're trying to build here on a land I purchased a few years back.
O!Sapiens Expert: Thanks, Martin.
wesley: uh, in the south of Thailand, and it's really, uh, kind of, like, resonating with what you're doing, uh, and what you want, so… so it's… the idea is to build.
wesley: A space where there's a community, there's wellness, there's longevity programs, everything integrated into one.
wesley: Space, where people can come for a specific amount of times, and then they can also generate.
wesley: passive income from renting out the properties that they're buying. So this is the way it's set up right now. It's kind of like a resort slash community, pretty much.
Martin: Okay, okay, cool.
wesley: Yep.
Martin: So, you attract more people.
Martin: who have a long stay there, or is more investors to for for rental.
wesley: Ideally, it will be… we will offer maybe up to a month for people that want to stay there, but it's also… there's also an option for people to stay longer if they want, and it could also be a place to come to when.
Martin: And…
wesley: There are issues, perhaps, you know, there's a lot of issues going on right now worldwide and a lot of instability. So it could also be something long term for them to come back in case, you know, things really, really turn pretty hourly, I will say.
Martin: Okay.
wesley: But yeah, the main point really is to get them to buy the units, and then have us manage it for them when they are not here.
Martin: Okay, okay, okay.
wesley: Yeah, yeah.
wesley: and also generate, you know, more income through workshops, you know, and wellness, food. I mean, there's a food forest that's planned also on the property. There's just a lot of amenities also that we want to.
Martin: Okay.
wesley: We want to put there. Yeah. So yeah.
Martin: And you are a founder or investor? What is your role there?
wesley: I'm, I'm a founder, uh, and, uh, I own the land, so I bought the land asset a few years back, uh, back in, in…
wesley: It was during COVID, so I've got around 5,000 square met.
wesley: There is a private lake on the place, more like a pond, like a large pond.
wesley: Uh, it's full of organic trees now that are growing, it's a beautiful space, it's in the valley, it's quite secluded, and there are options to expand the land, you know, next door, there's a large lot also that's not used.
wesley: Um, it's just a very unique space. It's on the main… yeah, it's not on an island, it's on the mainland in Nakhon Sitamarat.
Martin: Okay.
Martin: Yeah.
wesley: And there are hot springs nearby. The beach is around 7 to 10 minutes away. I mean, it's really a wonderful place. Yeah.
Martin: Okay. And tell me something about yourself. You're American or you live in where do you live?
wesley: Yeah, I…
wesley: Yeah, I lived in Thailand for about 14 years now. My background, yeah, my background is in real estate in the US and hospitality mostly, and I also worked in the wine business for a while.
Martin: Okay.
wesley: Um, and I've been here since 2013. Yeah. So, so I ventured in a few, uh, few businesses, uh, resorts and, and restaurants that I've opened around Thailand, uh, vegan restaurants also that I, that I own, that I sold.
wesley: And then real estate as well.
Martin: Okay, okay.
wesley: Yep.
Martin: And you live already there, and on the… in the…
wesley: I live in Koh Samui now, so I go back and forth between Koh Samui. I go to Koh Phangan as well, because there's a huge community there for wellness, and I'm really interested in that. So I go back and forth between Samui and Pei, and now I'm going more.
Martin: Ah, okay.
wesley: to the mainland to see the problem. Yeah, yeah. Have you seen the website?
Martin: Ah, okay, okay. Okay, okay.
Martin: Yeah, I think I grabbed the idea.
wesley: Okay, great, great, great.
wesley: Okay.
Martin: And, uh, yeah.
Martin: Where do you stand in the project? Is this…
wesley: So far, it's been a lot of talk to different investors. I haven't pushed, I think, enough as far as the marketing side to gather more people because I've been taken by other projects. So I haven't really prioritized that because to me, it's like the land asset is there and it's going to be there forever. And I think I've been taking a little bit too much time.
wesley: Um, to make it happen, but the few people that I've spoken to, they are very interested and turn on to the idea. Um, so we have a few people in the wellness, uh, that, that are, that are quite, uh, quite known. Um, I have.
wesley: another guy that wants to invest as well, a big chunk of capital in the property, and do the management. He has a property management company, and he wants to have exclusivity on management.
wesley: because it's a… it's a scalable project, he wants interest also maybe on… on other locations, perhaps, if we… if we come to develop more in Thailand, and then maybe globally.
Martin: Okay, okay. And when you…
wesley: So this is what I'm saying. I'm really… it's about capital now, really, just maybe having the first…
wesley: I'll say, you know, the first money to really stage it, and perhaps pre-sell the rest of the units.
Martin: Ah, okay, okay.
wesley: Yeah. Yeah.
wesley: Yep.
Martin: So, then you're gonna sell… when you start with selling, then, uh, what do you think?
wesley: Hopefully, as soon as we have the first phase done, the idea, I mean, the latest idea was to develop phase one with the restaurant, one lobby, one unit.
wesley: uh, that cost will be around $150K USD, and then, um, from that, getting, you know, started with a few workshops, getting people there, uh, to see the property, and perhaps invest on the units.
Martin: Okay, okay, but…
wesley: As, as pre-sales, yeah.
Martin: Okay, but it first start with the common infrastructure, with restaurant and with…
wesley: Yep.
wesley: I think it's wise. I mean, it's a new idea that was brought on by the latest investor, and I think it's a pretty good idea, you know, to have at least something that people can see, because people are a little bit worried now with off-plan, because there are a lot of projects that just, you know, they.
wesley: take money from investors and they never build. So it's quite an issue.
Martin: Yeah, I'll just not…
wesley: So they want to see something, yeah.
Martin: We just start with the sleeping units and then the rest never comes. Also happening.
wesley: Yep.
wesley: Exactly, exactly. So you get to show something, you know, in order for them to invest. And I had the experience also before from building resorts that until you have like a few buildings there.
wesley: it's very tough to raise, but as soon as you start, it's kind of like everyone wants to give you their money now, because they see it coming. Yeah.
Martin: Yeah, okay.
Martin: Yeah, I understand, I understand. So, when you talk about, you're on your own with this project, or are you a group, or you have founders?
wesley: Yeah, yeah.
wesley: No, no, no, it's just… I mean, the land asset belongs to me, and then, you know, Vlad is one of my partners now on the, you know, everything that's going to be…
wesley: Well, I'll say with related to wellness, I think he's a specialist and he's really, that's his field. So I'm going to leave that to him. As far as development of the property, I think that's more of my thing.
wesley: Sparking the project is really something that I can do quick and efficiently.
wesley: Raising funds, I can too, if I focus well, but lately it's been difficult in Thailand. There's a lot of issues, you know, going on with nominees and breakdowns and…
wesley: There's a lot of crackdowns on companies now, and not many setups. So the idea is to offer lease, long-term lease.
Martin: Yeah, yeah.
Martin: Okay, okay.
wesley: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
wesley: But yeah, I mean, that's, yeah, so far, just need a little bit of capital to get started, pretty much. Yeah.
Martin: Okay, okay.
Martin: Do you do a lot of promotion now? So social media? No, not yet. Okay.
wesley: No.
wesley: Not much, not much. I haven't done much. And that's actually why the latest investor was really interesting because he has a whole marketing team. And he proposed to actually do that and maybe take a lower risk by investing just on the first phase. So it will not be that big of a commitment. And then once we start selling maybe the three or four units that can finance the entire property, we can.
Martin: Okay.
Martin: Yeah.
wesley: Uh, he can actually inject more capital. So, and, and, and, yeah.
Martin: Okay, okay, okay, I see, I see. Okay, so, um, you, you stay long-term there in Thailand? You live there more or less, huh?
wesley: Yeah, exactly.
wesley: Yeah, I've been, I've been here for a long time, yeah, like, I'll be here for, for long, I.
Martin: Yeah.
Martin: You're not. You're not a traveler traveling around like me, and.
wesley: Uh, I travel when I can. Now, I've been quite, uh… I mean, I've been here a lot, because I really want to develop this project. I've been also working on other things. My son is Thai, he's going to school here, so for me, it's like…
Martin: Ah, Okay, Okay. und.
wesley: Um, yeah.
wesley: Very attached to Thailand.
Martin: Nee.
Martin: Ja. Okay, Cool. So, Ok.
wesley: Yeah.
Martin: I mean, I guess I will be in Thailand next winter again. Thailand… Asia, let's say Asia. And, uh… yeah, until then…
Martin: I don't expect that I should do anything, or we could wait until then.
wesley: Yep.
Martin: und.
Martin: And then we get in contact again, and then see you, and then I see the site, and then…
wesley: Sure, sure.
wesley: Yep.
Martin: Let's see what we're then taking from there.
wesley: What do you, um, uh, what are you looking for exactly? You're looking to, um, maybe commit capital yourself, or are you looking to maybe structure, maybe, the, the, the, the company to, to raise capital? I mean, what's, uh, what's your…
wesley: your… your specialty.
Martin: Uh, yeah, I mean…
Martin: main purposes is really have a plan B space where to live, yeah, to… not the whole year, but, uh, yeah, two, three, four months a year. And there, uh…
wesley: Yep.
Martin: And investment is not that important, so.
wesley: Mm-hmm, mm-h.
Martin: that the investment is… I mean, the revenues on the investment, yes, if something comes in, it's okay. So, I have passive income, so this is not my main focus to…
Martin: to, yeah, if the project is stable, if, if, uh, people are interesting, concept is interesting, yeah, I'm willing to, to, uh, to, yeah, to…
wesley: Yep.
wesley: Nice.
Martin: To go into that.
wesley: Yeah, the few, you know, the few ads I've placed, I mean, I think I've done it only one or twice, you know.
wesley: Um, it's gathered a lot of, of, uh…
wesley: a lot of interest, you know, somehow I had a lot of leads, and I mean, even…
wesley: If those leads didn't really follow through in the end, I think if more energy is put into marketing, I think there could be a lot of leads coming in, a lot of people interested in this project because there's not that many units. It's not a big ask also.
wesley: So it's not so hard, you know, to…
wesley: to finance the project, I think, like that.
Martin: Yeah, absolutely. Absolutely.
wesley: Yeah.
wesley: Uh, I spoke also, I spoke to another guy, he's an influencer in Phuket, he sells a lot of, uh, condominiums and real estate, and now he's really, uh, turned on by everything that has a theme, and mostly wellness, so also he's talking about maybe doing a podcast and trying to push.
wesley: you know, the property forward. So there's a few people like that that I talk to, but there's much more to be done, you know, for sure.
Martin: Yeah, yeah, yeah, I understand.
wesley: Yeah. Yeah.
Martin: Yeah, I mean, for the moment, it's okay. I mean, it's good that we have a… we could connect afterwards. Jan…
wesley: Good, good.
wesley: Not sure.
Martin: LinkedIn also.
wesley: Yeah, yeah. I need to update my LinkedIn, I think.
O!Sapiens Expert: Mmhm.
Martin: Okay. Vlad, Vlad will help us to, to, to, uh, connect.
wesley: And I think we need to put the property on.
O!Sapiens Expert: Yeah, I'll connect you soon.
wesley: Yep.
O!Sapiens Expert: Mmhm.
Martin: And yeah, and then.
Martin: If there is anything going on, let me know.
wesley: Sure, sure.
Martin: And hopefully, yes, we, we, I will, we will meet in.
Martin: Later then. Yes, I also was in Copenhagen many times. It's a cool place. I mean, many people from Bali go to Copenhagen, I have the feeling.
wesley: Yeah, it's nice.
wesley: It's very spiritual, so I think a lot of people…
O!Sapiens Expert: And vice versa.
Martin: Yeah, it's…
Martin: Yeah, yeah, it's cool, it's cool.
wesley: And what's great is that, um, because, I mean, I don't know if it's great for copywriting, but there.
wesley: It's quite saturated now, so, so a lot of people are looking for other options, and they're looking for places that are a little bit more outside of the islands, a little bit more secluded, so that's when, uh, a place like, uh, um, uh, Nacom City Marat comes in, because.
Martin: Yeah. Okay.
wesley: It's really easy access by boat. I was at a spot actually south of Samui just now, and within like 45 minutes by speedboat, you can get to the mainland. So it's very easy to go back and forth. It's got international airports, like two or three international airports nearby.
wesley: Um, I mean, it's so easy for them to get off the island and find another space, like, that's more, um…
wesley: I'll say more like Thailand, yeah, yeah.
O!Sapiens Expert: Chilled.
Martin: Yeah, yeah, yeah, absolutely. I mean, this all have the problem. Also, Bali has the problem.
wesley: Yep.
O!Sapiens Expert: Mmm.
Martin: Too little bit overcrowded, over-tourist, traffic, and yeah.
wesley: Yep.
wesley: Yeah, that's what they're going to. They're going to Lombok. I think a lot of people are going to different spots.
Martin: And then.
Martin: Yeah, absolutely. Absolutely.
O!Sapiens Expert: Yeah, and this place is not that crowded, which is beautiful.
wesley: Good, good.
wesley: Yeah, yeah.
O!Sapiens Expert: I mean, the plot of land isn't more…
Martin: You have been there, Vlad?
O!Sapiens Expert: Yeah, I have. Yeah, it's really nice. The area is not that developed. There is no traffic at all. It's very relaxed and chill. It's really nice.
Martin: You have been there?
wesley: Yep.
Martin: Yeah.
wesley: Right.
Martin: Then you have to have a good program, otherwise people get bored.
O!Sapiens Expert: Yeah, for sure.
wesley: Yeah, yeah, yeah, I mean, that's the thing. The thing is, if I was to, I'll say, live in that area, you know, alone, I don't know if I would be there, you know.
wesley: Uh, full time, I think I will be traveling a lot, uh, back and forth between the islands to just to, to have like some kind of connections with people, but, but lately it's been developing in the area and more and more foreigners are seen, they are more emphasis on wellness.
Martin: Yes.
wesley: So there are three centers popping up. It's really moving in a slow pace, but which is good because if you really build something that's meaningful, I think it's going to attract a lot of people.
Martin: Yeah, absolutely.
wesley: The fact that it's been away, yeah.
Martin: Absolutely. It's cool. Yeah, that's…
O!Sapiens Expert: Um, Martin, quick question before we wrap up. I wanted to ask you about the place that you're looking for. Do you have, like, um, I don't know, criteria, like, check marks, like, this has to be there, or this is, like, uh, something that you don't want to be in a resort like this, because we're still in the planning phase, and, you know.
O!Sapiens Expert: the feedback could be taken into consideration.
Martin: Yeah, I can send you… Yeah, I can send you a mail. I write down some ideas. So really, my priorities. So what I would really…
O!Sapiens Expert: Thank you.
Martin: I've seen many places, you know, they all come with longevity and wellness, and they also all have a sauna, they all have a gym, of course.
wesley: Yep.
Martin: And the ice baths, this is, but…
O!Sapiens Expert: By default.
Martin: But you need to program a little bit, or you need…
O!Sapiens Expert: Oh, that's easy. Just give it the space. I mean, there are so many healers. I mean, here in Barcelona, it's insane.
Martin: Yeah.
wesley: Yep.
wesley: Yeah.
Martin: Domain you want?
O!Sapiens Expert: Half of them are spending… healers of all modalities, like, whatever you want.
Martin: Ah, he knows.
Martin: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
O!Sapiens Expert: And then in Copenhagen as well.
wesley: Yeah, I think, I think I saw, like.
wesley: Yeah, you can find quite a lot of people that are also… that have strong influence, you know, and will gather more and more, you know, people to come and join the workshop. So, getting people that are actually anchored into.
wesley: Um…
wesley: their, their industries, you know, as far as, as, as wellness, and there are specialists of what they're doing worldwide, that would be great. So we want to get really good people there, um, just for that, just to gather a nice network. And, um, and I think, like, yeah, I mean, the typical, you know, infrastructure will be, you know, we will have a sauna, we will have maybe a steam room, and.
O!Sapiens Expert: Hmm.
wesley: and jacuzzi or ice bath, but it will have to be differentiated from what's done everywhere else. You know, you can integrate the infrared inside the sauna. You can do mineral bath with shilajit.
wesley: into a hot tub. You can do… you can integrate different music or sounds into the steam room. There's a lot of things you can do and differentiate yourself from everyone else.
Martin: Ja. Ja. Ja.
Martin: Absolutely, absolutely, Ja, ja.
wesley: Yeah. yeah, the use, the use of like non non aluminum use or non non plastic, you know, like all that you would have to be really meticulous in all the material that you're using, you know, because that goes into your skin and into your body.
Martin: Ja ja absoluutli.
wesley: That stuff. Yeah, yeah.
wesley: So it's very, it's got to be very, we got to take it a step forward. Yeah.
wesley: Uh, yeah.
wesley: Yep.
Martin: Hull.
wesley: Nice.
O!Sapiens Expert: Amazing, Martin. Yeah, if you could send us your wish list, that'd be great.
Martin: Yeah, my wish list, my personal wish list, it's super.
wesley: Yeah.
O!Sapiens Expert: Hmm.
wesley: Very nice.
Martin: Ja.
wesley: Well, great to meet you then.
O!Sapiens Expert: Amazing.
Martin: Jah, võistle.
O!Sapiens Expert: Yeah. Thanks for the time, huh?
wesley: When are you planning to come here?
Martin: Jaa.
wesley: Okay. Okay.
O!Sapiens Expert: Like, November, December this year?
wesley: All right.
Martin: December, januari, februar. Something like that.
wesley: The rainy season, the rainy season rains quite a lot in December.
Martin: Ja.
Martin: Jaa, nüüd.
Martin: Its, good for me.
wesley: Yeah, yeah, yeah. January, February is good.
Martin: Ja.
O!Sapiens Expert: But it's still nice.
wesley: Yeah.
wesley: Okay, great, well, nice to meet you, uh, we'll speak very soon, keep in touch. I'll get your contact from, uh, um…
Martin: Jah.
wesley: Yeah, from Vlad and then continue the talks. Yeah. Okay.
O!Sapiens Expert: Yep.
Martin: Jah.
O!Sapiens Expert: Cool. Have a lovely day, gentlemen.
Martin: Tiiu.